a huge thank you to everyone for making
this such a special evening
I would say a few words about my father
and why I believe this weekend is so
important
but don't worry unlike Lionel I won't go
on all night long
as my grandmother said when she was
crowned coronations are a declaration of
our hopes for the future
and I know she's up there fondly keeping
an eye on us and she'll be a very proud
mother
for all that celebrations are
magnificent at the heart of the
pageantry is a simple message
service
my father's first words on Entry
Westminster Abbey yesterday were a
pledge of service
it was a pledge to continue to serve
because for over 50 years in every
corner of the UK across the Commonwealth
and around the world he has dedicated
himself to serve others both current and
future generations and those whose
memory must not be neglected
take the natural world
he warned us of the risks to our
planet's Health long before it was an
everyday issue
or the prince's trusts
it is supported
the prince's trust is supported over a
million young people many from
disadvantaged backgrounds to realize
their ambitions
and perhaps most importantly of all my
father has always understood that people
of all faiths all backgrounds and all
communities deserve to be celebrated and
supported
Paul
we are all so proud of you
and I also want to express my pride and
gratitude for the millions of people who
serve in the forces in classrooms
Hospital Wards and local communities
I wish I could mention you all
your service inspires us and tonight we
celebrate you too
I commit myself to serve you all
King country and Commonwealth
God Save the King
[Applause]